RNA Peak another program here at Shiraki.
it's also very good program
for those people who want to apply.
the communities participating in this program.
so Jimmy to see put through it
that you have one year of experience.
so should I hear one year the experience
it is required to be in the last 3 years.
and it is experienced
not to say part time jobs.
and we calculate curts and even your full time jobs.
we calculate
curts that these jobs can be different occupations.
uh, these jobs can be with different employers.
so if you meet all the eligibility requirements
under this program
and the community requirements.
the community will provide you with the recommendation.
and then you can apply for your PR
under are in IP. thank you.